للمرة الثالثة هذا الأسبوع ،
دخل ماساتومي يوكو وفريقه إلى منزل
لتنظيف وظيفة بسيطة
ولكن لا شيء بخصوص هذا الأمر سهل
، ربما مات هنا لا أعرف
الشكل لأن سائل الجسم قد غرق
في حصير التاتامي كثيرًا
ولكني أعتقد  ربما هنا ، كان
رئيس شركة الذكريات يعمل
في مجال التنظيف منذ حوالي 13
عامًا ،
لكنه قال مؤخرًا إن التنظيف بعد
الموت الوحيدي
حيث يموت الناس بمفردهم ويظلون
غير مكتشفين لفترات طويلة من الوقت
قد تحول للأسف إلى شركة كبيرة
نقوم بهذا النوع من العمل كل  اليوم هذا
المشهد هو أننا نشهد دائمًا
يمكننا أن نرى أن حياته تزداد
صعوبة وأنه يصدر استغاثة
هذا مشهد عادي بالنسبة لنا
الرجل البالغ من العمر 79 عامًا الذي عاش هنا توفي
وحده وسبب الوفاة غير معروف الشرطة تقول
له.  تم العثور على الجثة بعد حوالي شهر
من وفاته وهي
تتجول في هذه الشقة ، يبدو الأمر كما
لو أن الوقت قد توقف ، لا يزال هناك
طعام
وشراب على البريد المضاد على
الأرض وإذا ألقيت نظرة حول هذه
الشقة
هناك قمامة وملابس متناثرة في
كل مكان ، إنه مشهد مفجع ،
إنه شائع جدًا هنا في اليابان.  وجدت معظم
أبحاثها التي
تحلل الصحة العقلية للجمهور
أن 40
من جميع السكان اليابانيين يشعرون
بالوحدة
لأولئك الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 40 عامًا ، هذا الرقم هو 50 في
المائة
لديهم أفكار انتحارية عالية
يريدون الانتحار في
كثير من الأحيان ثم يشعرون أيضًا
أنهم عديم الفائدة لأنهم  ليس لها أي
معنى في الحياة ،
لذا فإن التأثير النفسي
للوحدة على الفرد
مرتفع جدًا وهو تأثير نفسي من
المحتمل أن يؤثر على المزيد من الأشخاص
نتيجة للوباء
في عام 2020 ولأول مرة منذ 11 عامًا ،
ارتفع معدل الانتحار في
اليابان عن العام السابق  وتغير
ما حدث عادة خلال
الأزمة الاقتصادية حيث يموت الرجال في منتصف العمر
د عن طريق الانتحار ، لكن الآن الأمر يتعلق بالشابات ،
لذا من المؤكد أن هناك شيئًا
مختلفًا يحدث
، وتشير الأرقام إلى أن الأمر يزداد سوءًا
وفقًا لوكالة الشرطة الوطنية ، فقد
زاد معدل الانتحار في شهر أبريل
بنسبة تزيد عن 19 بالمائة
مقارنة بشهر أبريل الماضي بينما كان
الوباء قد انتشر  أودى بحياة أكثر من 10000
شخص في اليابان خلال ذلك الوقت ،
أكثر من 23000 شخص
انتحروا من أجل ناناكو تاكاياما.هذه الأرقام
شخصية لقد
عانت من اكتئاب الوحدة
وتفكرت في الانتحار عندما كانت
تبلغ من العمر 30 عامًا
بعد وقت قصير من ولادة طفلها الأول.
أردت أن تختفي ، لم أكن أعرف
كيف أتعامل مع مشاعري ، وكان من
المؤلم للغاية التفكير فيما يجب فعله بعد
حوالي عقد من الزمن ، يدرس تاكاياما
علم النفس وهو مستشار في anata
no ibasho وهو مكان مناسب لك
وهو محادثة على مدار 24 ساعة  خدمة
لأولئك الذين يحتاجون فقط إلى من يستمع إليهم
في بعض الأحيان تتفاعل مع أربعة إلى خمسة
أشخاص يوميًا ،
فهي تستخدم صراعها مع
الوحدة لمساعدة الآخرين
أريد أن أقول إنك لست وحدك ، فنحن
نرغب بجدية في الاستماع إلى قصتك التي
تعبر عن قلقك ليس
شيئًا سيئًا أبدًا ، ولا يعني ذلك أنك
تهرب من المشكلة
أو أنك ضعيف الخبراء يقولون حوالي
30000 شخص  هنا في اليابان يموتون
وحيدا كل عام ، وعندما يحدث ذلك ،
هذه
هي النتيجة التي طُلب من عمال النظافة الحضور
لالتقاط قطع الحياة المفقودة ،
لا يمكنني التعود على هذا
الوقت الذي توقف هنا إلى الأبد ، يمكنني أن أشعر
بنوع الحياة  كان يواجه هنا على الفور
يتحدث بصراحة عن وجع قلبي